well Dan Perry is the former head of the
Associated Press in Europe the Middle
East and Africa joins us live from Tel
Aviv good to have you with us so what
Israel was seeking at this stage was to
have the whole case thrown out of court
it failed to get that today
right yeah it's a mix back for Israel
they had hoped indeed for the Court to
declare that this is not genocide which
by the way as someone who knows the UN
genocide convention by heart I have to
personally agree that indeed uh the term
does not apply genocide may be the one
thing that Israel is not guilty of in in
in Gaza so yes Israel was disappointed
that that was not stated out right on
the other hand there had been a fear
that the court would order uh a halt to
the fighting would issue a temporary
injunction demanding an end to the
fighting now remember the court doesn't
have powers of enforcement that would
then go to the Supreme to the UN
Security Council presumably the us would
have vetoed it there but it would have
been very very awkward for Israel that
didn't happen so there is some relief in
Israel that that worst case scenario
didn't happen the rest of it essentially
belongs in a real of politics right and
you've pointed out your personal opinion
but of course coming back to the fact of
the story today that this court found
plausibility of the intent to commit
genocide on 16 Prof six provisional
measures
this not find
imp to be accur right and it ordered six
Israel to take six measures to prevent
genocide that puts Israel in a very
difficult position doesn't it especially
Vis A World opinion if you've been told
on six counts to change your behavior
that's not a good day for you is
it uh again I rever to what I said there
had been uh fear in Israel that the cour
Court would order an end to the fighting
that didn't happen sure Israel got
wrapped on a Knuckles and
uh I I can't argue with that particular
ruling by the court but I underscore the
icj does not have powers of uh of
enforcement only the UN Security Council
can can can do that uh countries across
the world view is
r
aeran was ordered by the icj to stop its
blockade of Nordo kabak last February it
didn't even bother to states that it
won't it just ignored it altogether
nothing happened the reason nothing
happened is because the UN Security
Council lacked the political will to
make it happen that is the reality about
the icj we shall see what happens at the
Iran Security Council I'm not saying
Israel should continue uh as if nothing
has occurred there are very plausible
very reasonable criticisms one can level
uh uh against Israel's conduct of the
war and I you know I you mentioned my
opinion before I'll give you another
opinion I think Israel should absolutely
engage with the Biden administration's
effort to engineer a mega deal to end
the war it should probably agree to give
amnesty to the Hamas leadership to leave
Gaza and perhaps go to Qatar but it's a
complex situation and there is
Disappointment in Israel by the way for
sure that the court um did not state
clearly an understanding of what
actually happened here in a larger
scheme of things which is which is the
the government of Gaza in the form of
Hamas staged what is without question a
genocidal invasion of Israel on October
7th and Israel is reacting to it and has
decided on something that I believe the
entire Western World at least agrees
which is that Hamas right let me just
correct one thing said actually in the
summary judgment it does reference the
October 7th attacks but anyway coming
away from aeran and other well because
the the case put forward by South Africa
was to focus on prevention of genocide
uh by Israel I I believe that's question
whether the if we come
to question at hand now is this going to
increase the split between the Biden
Administration and the Netanyahu
government I do not think the icj's
ruling is going to increase the split I
think the split is there it's real Biden
needs the war to end quickly Biden needs
uh Israel to engage with his what I
believe are his good faith efforts to
create a landscape that enables uh a lot
of good things for the region which
might include a Sunni Israel Western
axis against Iran which might include
indeed the removal of hos from power and
Gaza which I think the entire Western
World wants which might include a return
of the hostages to Israel those who are
alive I think netanyahu's um rejection
of uh of of of any of any notion of
engaging with with that um Proposal with
such emerging proposals with even the
idea of articulating an endgame for Gaza
is most unfortunate and in reality what
will create pressure on Israel is
increasing opposition both from the West
specifically from America and also
within Israeli public opinion to
netanyahu's uh policy of avoiding any
talk of a day after Hamas and Gaza but I
have to say the idea that hostages
should be returned and that hamash
should be removed from power in Gaza is
very popular in Israel and in the west
and I should think it is actually
popular uh in the Arab world as well
if if if if the Palestinians have an
enemy I actually think that enemy is
more Hamas in Israel realistically Hamas
has been trying for 30 to prevent the
practition of the Holy Land into a
two-state solution and anyone who knows
history should be aware of that so the
idea of conf let's come back and focus
palan naal interest let's focus on the
icj ruling do you think there's any
chance that the Netanyahu government
will take any steps to try and show he's
abiding At All by this
ruling I think they'll take proor steps
uh my guess is they're going to be
celebrating the fact that they didn't
order an enter the fighting as I've said
and yeah they'll issue a report in a
month and they will claim that they have
they are doing as they'll claim they
have done all along all they can to
avoid civilian casualties one can
believe or disbelieve that I you know I
mean I I I I I hate to not cooperate
with the premise of the question but I
don't think the icj ruling moves the
needle I think if we want the needle
moved that comes from political pressure
applied by Biden in the western world
upon n clearly and by the way would for
the Arab world to
apply of the judges disagreed with that
they've they've ordered measures to be
taken immediately medely by Israel for
Israel not to cover up Acts of genocide
and for Israel to report back do you
think Israel will even report back
within a month on how much compliance
it's it's giving that's a good question
that's a good question I I now now look
this is this is an an assessment my
assessment is that yes they will they're
going to try to make it um they're going
to try to make it appear as if they're
indeed compliant but with the content of
that report within a month will it
satisfy Israel's
critics I I'm skeptical all right thanks
so much Dan Perry for joining
us thank you